[Music]
hello everyone good afternoon welcome to
the a iff structure and the to o session
this session we will have two talks one
is about optimizer back here analyzer
for deep learning computation another
one is for AI platform so I'm Jerusha
from Mexico research asa so I will start
first talk it's glad to introduce this
our recent project called volume a
backhand or measure for deep learning
computation in recent years deep
learning has gained many success in the
area such as vision and speech and an LP
and so on along with the success there
are many emerging innovations so in one
side the deeper insights are recited are
continuously inventing new models and
workload patterns for example beyond the
irons in the typical models there are
also new workload patterns like again
reinforcement learning and graph newer
networks so in other side the hardware
vendors are actually matching new
accelerators for speed up is a
commutation for example beyond the CPU
GPU and a PGA there are some more and
more new accelerators accelerators and
high-speed network links so within this
situation several deep learning
frameworks were proposed for example
like test follows in TK Kaffee - for
user to easily write to TN program and
computer on different hardware devices
typically is this frameworks abstract
deep learning competition as a data flow
graph the the notation Rapids to permit
operators and edge represents the tensor
data so using data flow graph is a
problem why are two gates efficient
expensive and the programming
flexibility however it also brains the
challenge of how to effectively do crack
computation over different devices so we
think a systematic way is to leverage a
compiler and the optimizer a miser
infrastructure to bridge the airframe
work
and the hardware this is because
compiler can combine both the
information from application pattern and
the hardware feature to make a path to
match as it has the global view of the
data flow graph so the compiler analyzer
can also do of meisa for distributed
computation does the search
infrastructure is the critical for both
the training and the inference narrow
based on this observation we start our
research project when years ago so our
we proposed a system called Walloon
which is a miser stack for deep learning
computation the motivation who is to
address deep learning performance
organization problem in your systematic
way specifically we're going to leverage
is a general graph graph organization
passes and the leveraging the principle
of software and hardware device code
design and it just just-in-time compiler
the right figure is the architecture of
alone one has three optimizer module the
global advisor local miser and tensor
placement and advisor so the global
miser is has a global view of the
computation graph and the contacts
distributed organization through
partitioning and leverages the hardware
features and the localizer mainly on
lies the sub graph after the graph
partitioning for a specific device never
using the J's compiler and the tensor
placement visor mainly on mice for a
tensor layout and the placement
houses organization world were designing
automatic and transparent way so the
world generated targets use organizes
the efficient the communication and the
execution and the memory efficiencies so
first let's look at a case of global of
Mizer the subtitle is fast distribute
deep learning computation over our DMA
as I introduced it before a deep
learning computation is modeled as a
data flow graph
to ask you the data flow graph in
distributed Silver's so theorem work
first need to partition the graph and
the dispatch each sub graph to
corresponding servers after partitioning
f0 is n to go across to Silver's we are
in we need to insert a pair of stand and
receive notes so this pair of will note
are responsible for a real real data
transmission during a computation
I was to mention this Qaeda home
mechanism is general to express both of
the modal / ISM that they did Haris
pattern which are a common way to scale
deep learning competition in the tribute
servers in such a general framework the
communication has to leverage a general
communication library however in most
deep learning scenarios the tensor
transmission in such a framework brings
significant overhead which becomes a
major bottleneck for scalability to
demonstrate this we use a simple micro
benchmark which just send a tensor with
different size from one server to
another server this figure measure is
the the latency the the which offers
different different sensor size as we
can see as we can see even use a similar
same network there is up to 10x latency
gap between the general RPC library and
a well-organised the program which
carefully leverage our DMA so to
understand the overhead of our PC let's
go to a little bit more details we
observed that major hello
RPC is caused by memory copy and it is
inherently I avoid above for such a
general library this is because the
general idea is designed for dynamic
dynamic data structure and it's a lack
of knowledge about the actual data
placement and the message size as
illustrated in the right figure a
message set from sender to the - from
sender has to be first copied from
application memory - to the RPC managed
memory and they are sterilised into a
larger buffer to better leverage the
battery fish
say corresponding at this service
distillation and the memory copy also
happened in the receiver side to adjust
this overhand we cannot elaborate just
such a general library instead we can we
should use a right time adviser which
can dynamically decide the memory
placement according to a specific
computation workload and the next
network topology to completely remove
the memory overhead just in our
distributed guava organization we
combined both the properties of
computing a graph and our DM net will
feature first for the tensor data that
tensor structure unlike the general
method type the terms of data in deep
running our computation has there were
special properties first it consists of
a play byte array with sufficiently
large size often from several kilobyte
to megabyte due to this we actually do
not require data serialization the
teaser ization
is in this kind of transmission due to
access pattern of tensor it's already
already scheduled we also do not require
extra batch in but how this information
can only be decided in the right time so
second with our DMA hardware and the
protocol we can manage both the local
and distributed memory in a unified view
we can do efficient a memory copy
between host memory through the one side
our DNA and the read and write
primitives and the facial memory copy
the 20 best memory to to to host memory
with GPU debug our DMA just a global
graph optimizer fault it should be the
computation is a systematic way to
address to get ability of the offer work
this is because first global miser care
has interviewed interview of and the
control of the memory placement among
the devices servers second date is the
capable of making global of mice the
strategy for the voltage sensor data
placement in the right time so based on
these observations we designed a new
communication mechanism in our of my
servo distributed computation over our
DMA in this mechanism it has a two
phases
the graph in oullette analyzing phase
and the graph execution phase first
before the graph is a real executed
there is a graph analyzing phase in the
centre side our advisor first attack a
physical member address of the standing
tensor and that tells the information to
the tensor manager to reallocate it as
the our DME compatible memory so this
can dynamically avoid the memory copy in
the center side similarly in the
receiver side is your graph for
analyzing we can know the receive in
tensor sight before hand so we can pre
allocate the recipient answer as our DME
comparable memory to avoid the receiver
side the memory copy overhead so after
the graph analyzing phase in the
execution phase when the center Center
center node is ready to send its host
answer it can't just issue one side our
DMA write command and our Dominic will
directly copy the sauced answer to test
the tensors memory in the receiver side
since the our DMA didn't has the
notification mechanism so the the
receive operator will continuously
pulling our flag bite until the value
would turn to one which means the whole
tensor data has already already arrived
so it can be so it can just simply pass
the reference of tensor to the downside
of critters as we can see this
communication magnesium over of Mizer
we can completely remove the memory copy
overhead in the post sender side and the
receiver side and most importantly
without affecting the usability so this
is the performance evaluation for our
optimized the communication mechanism on
both deep learning frameworks and the
real chaining were workload so our
experiments are conducting a cluster
with eight servers to evaluate a
performance we implement our of my
serene tensor flow the left figure shows
the training throughput of transceiver
law and our optimizer version on a set
of deep deep learning batch marks
including iron seein and
Reconnective work as we can see with our
transparent organization in same
hardware Europe environments the
performance can be improved from one
point eight times to eight point one
times we also demonstrated the benefit
to our end-to-end the sequence sequence
to sequence translation model uses
public datasets which is a showing in
the right figure the y-axis is a
perplexity which measures a convergence
equality the lowered batter and the
accesses it's a training time as we can
see with organization the convergence it
can be speed up by two to three times
so after demonstrates the benefit of our
global advisor for distributed deep
learning computation now let's look at
our case of localizer so we are mainly
talking about the kernel fusion for deep
learning and GPU the localizer is really
amazing a subgraph on a specific device
currently we merely target to GPU so so
as I introduced Lee before deep learning
framework often model the computer TN
composition as a graph of operators
using graph has several under one cages
first it has a good expressivity and to
represent a virtually in your network
structure through just composing the
graph with primitive operators second it
is flexible to run the graph on multiple
device or multiple servers through just
the different equal partition strategies
however this flexibility comes with a
significant overhead since the typical
DNA model contains thousands even more
operators scheduling overhead is the
major bottleneck for the computation so
this two schedule in this overhead will
introduce the overhead like you cannot
launch our hand and the cross operator
communication overhead and also since
the primitive operator is the two fine
grade it is hard to leverage vendors
library for a specific computation
workload to demonstrate this
to demonstrate this we compared the
execution time of a 80 step Alice TM
model in ten Civello and the kudiye
kudiye is the vendor provided the
library from nvidia interest flow this
model is constructed by about one
thousand and six hundred operators and
the framework has to schedule all the
operators in this sub graph during the
computation
however in Korean says it is highly
optimized for removing the scheduler
scheduling overhead it can be a girl
order of magnitude at performance
improvements for the same workload we
also try to manually fuse all the
kernels on in the code into one CUDA
kernel it shows we can get similar
performance with ku DN so now let's have
a high-level comparison of the deep
learning frameworks and the hardware's
physical library in terms of programming
flexibility and the computational
efficiency and this is general challenge
of in currently tier frameworks first
first the tip running frameworks like
tensorflow
potage and the same TK has designed for
user to easily easily program they're
dipped in models and just they mostly
embrace the flexibility as explicitly
through using the graph of Auditors to
model computation but they they target
less about the performance extreme forms
the organization's the other side that
in libraries are gem are designed by
hardware vendors to push the extreme
performance boundary
however due to they are mostly hand tool
and highly organized for serviceable
sub-module so it is impossible to handle
customized or new network structure
which means we have good efficiency but
the poor flexibility to support a
virtual model thus if we have a if we
have a compiler that can dynamically
generate the library like a code in the
right time based on input data flow
graph for deep learning frameworks we
can get both the flexibility of
different work and the computation
efficiency
so under this situation we propose that
compiler stack for optimizing deep
learning computation so-called welcome
compiler takes input as a computation
graph and it has two optimizing
organization layers the graph level
organizer and the target specific data
compiler the graph level organizer
applies a set of target independent
graph from organization passes through
guava rewriting so common such as CSEE
comes folding and so on so auspice space
special organization user layer is the
operator patching which can
automatically patch the same type of
operators to better leverages patch
efficiency which I will introduce it
later the second layer is the target
specifically the compiler which can fuse
and the compiler sub graph into
efficient kernel currently we mainly
target to GPU device optimization in
this visor include static u-shaped so
they take shape inference and the tab
universe and the specific memory
planning and aggressive kernel fusion so
here is the this is a general execution
flow of volume compiler the graph
levelizer works before the graphic
fusion and the JIT compiler works during
execution first in the graph levelizer
when getting an input graph it first
detects some sub graph that can apply
optimizations for example if the graph
contains several same type operators the
operator batching pass will
automatically merge these operators into
a larger one to grant rewriting so after
the graph organization we start to the
real we start to do real execution for
super graph that is the first time to be
executed our compiler will conduct the
shape universe and the type inference
for this sub graph as well as a static
memory planning process based on the
graph and the GPU features after that we
automatically generate a fused to kernel
code for for the whole
sub graph and this user J the compiler
to compile the code into a new kernel
finally we replace this replace this
current because the original operators
in the sub graph with this annual
current new new compile the kernel and
then execute it so in literature
iterations if the graph and the input
shapes has never been changed
it will hit the couch and the directory
executed from pre compile the kernel
since we dynamically fused other
operators of the sub graph into a single
kernel it can't remove remove all the
scheduling overhead you fall inside
every introduced case of operator
batching and the details of a JIT
compiler so first let's look at how the
operator batching in graph levelizer
works here we introduce the case of
matrix-matrix multiplication merging as
we know mission milk multiplication is a
very common operator Indian workload it
has the mathematical equivalent aloose
if too many operator shares one same
input answer we can concatenate to the
other inputs to merge these two many
more and larger one the outputs of the
merge the memo is equivalent to the
contamination of the outputs of the two
original memo operate operators based on
this issue we can actually automatically
detect this pattern in our optimizer and
the rewrite to the graph to insert
concoct and the spirit operator to the
tumors of the memo to automatically
momentum operators so after Cauvery
writing we can do further organizations
so overt answer
placement of miser will get this
information and it will track this input
answer and allocate them you know
physically please continue self is the
memory so that the Kincaid operator can
avoid the memory copy during its
computation as illustrated in the right
figure with such kind of a graph level
rewriting organization and the memory
placement organization we can
transparently organize the graph for
better performance
so after the guava organization let's
move to the JIT compiler part after yeah
move to the JIT compiler part so in this
talk we really focus on how to do the
kernel fusion in our to the compiler
compared with the other optimization
frameworks our goal is to conduct a very
aggressive kernel fusion ideally we
would like to fuse the whole sub graph
into a single kernel to completely
remove scheduling overhead first let's
start from Adam to whites kernel fusion
this type of type of operators includes
binary operator operators like the end
sub x divided and so on and the unit
operators like sigmoid riilu and so on
for example if we want to compute a
sigmoid of X 1 plus X to the right of
the computation graph constructed by
doea framework will contain 2 elemental
operators and the sigmoid operator and
so in the left figure so the right
figure is a corresponding element or
wise data dependency graph as we can see
for an otherwise operator there is no
cross element dependency for this
computation so so we can simply a size
the computation for each element to a
single GPU thread and leverage is the on
triple register memory to share your
intermediate results so the general so
for this kind of workload for this work
out the generated of the code look
nicely in the figure it's it's it's a
really terrible a triple since the
fusion and wise kernel is really simple
so many other compiler currently also
score this kind of of fusion
however fusion just analyzed a preacher
we think is gnarly enough because the
invoice operator only occupies a very
small fraction of the the other
operators sets
let's our goal is to do aggressive
kernel fusion to fuse RPG operators to
support average confusion there are some
challenging heed to adjust first
unlikely the element wise operator - now
I am the wise operator alpha has across
data element dependencies we have to
carefully control the dependency for
each convenience thread second grade
level global synchronization inquiry is
a critical permitting for such kind of
workload fusion however current GPU
architecture has fundamental challenge
to support a general global
synchronization third some communication
between operator has to rely on the
device memory which may increase the
memory usage we have to carefully
optimize the memory usage and above
allocation to get better understand
let's look at an example of fusion to
continuous memory metamour operator
since each thread of the Second
Amendment has to read almost out the
data element from other thread of the
First Amendment
so a really typical way to do the fusion
I used to store the result first matmo
into the device memory and the second
memo can directly read the inputs from
intermediate buffer so right figure in
pseudocode for this kind of fusion we
can see we insert a global barrier
between the two metal function call so
however the fact is the interview
architecture this kind of code is really
challenged the to run so to understand
why this is the challenge happening for
GPU architecture so - first we need to
understand let's look look at how the
current DRM works schedule a data flow
graph in GPU so typically the Tian firm
worker uses a few to schedule operators
and the GPU is responsible for executing
each of ITER's kernel so the GPU often
consists of several stream processors
which can concurrently execute a block
task of the GPU kernel let's say there
is a graph with only two operators
Manimal and the convolution so the
convolution in the
the result of a memo to run this graph
in GPU the tr4 work has to schedule this
to cook two operators one by one for
each operator we need to explicitly
split it as multiple blog tasks
according the according to the data size
and schedule amount if you to to to
multiple GPU stream processors do to
limit the number of stream processors
the Polacks has to be implicitly
executed in several batches like this so
then the second operator is scheduled in
the similar way as I mentioned before if
the graph contains a lot of operators
the kernel launching and the operator
scheduler will become a significant
overhead so a straightforward way to
remove this overhand is the fusing of
the operator of subgraph into a single
tpo kernel for example if we want to
refuse the matter more and the
convolutional reading for single kernel
so we can compose them as two states the
first place into the Manimal and the
second stage do the convolution so
consequently the the outer product has
to also include a two stage however
since the this - kernel has a cross
where the data dependencies we have to
insert a barrier between the two stage
in the kernel so so so for the outer
Loxley how also has it so each block has
to enter a global barrier however as I
mentioned before due to limited as sm
resources only the first several blocks
of the kernel were real as scheduled
they will be blocked in waiting for
barrier so so as GPU has the no block
contacts which the later several blocks
will never be scheduled so this kernel
will fail to execute so to address this
issue by proposed to use the possesses
read and watch opa-locka magnetism to
fuse the same two operators into a
single kernel we first the limit is the
number of physical blocks of the fusion
fears the kernel according to the
available resources so that all the
kernels can be X so all the Polacks can
be executed concurrently
then we treated original blocks of each
operator as a worship block and assign
them to physical blocks in a row
drumming way we implemented this through
remapping their block ID in the code
generation time then we are free to
insert a barrier between the two stage
of virtual blocks since I was physical
are already active with this mechanism
we can fuse our kernel into a single GPU
as long as we can generate each
operators cells code so till now to fuse
multiple operators we are actually
actually generating a static sequence of
code for each operator for example for
the left two data flow graph with three
operators 0b sequentially assigned to
physical blocks like this however since
to the sigmoid let's see the figure the
graph since the sigmoid operator and the
end of with her are small critters and
they have no data dependencies so for if
we use the current idea framework as you
know we can we can leverage the data
parallel we can leverage the data
paralyzation so so so in all refuse and
frameworks there is some under
utilization for GPU resources to further
push this resource usage with Sparta
kernel packing mechanism which can pack
the small kernels into a more compact
way during the virtual block assignment
so we can fuse the we can pack the
animal and operator in into the sigmoid
operators patch in this way we can
explore the graph level paralyze them
paralyze and the removed kernel launch
overhead in the same time okay so this
is a way of how to generate refused to
use the kernel coding over compiler
basically we firstly need to register
for each operator we need to register
its kernel source code and some other
meta information to our code generator
we can only fuse operator that has been
registered for orbit to graph to be
fused
we first can
ship inference and the memory place
planning pass and then generates the
function calls for each operators for
example we can fold this graph we can
first generate a sigmoid and then the
meta Moe and final is for the riilu
operators like in this way so during the
process we will automatically insert a
barrier we needed and the packing kernel
if you possible currently we already
spots a lot of lot of operators we are
still and more into the framework so now
let's look at a premium promise game of
confusion for the our inference
benchmark with 88 steps as TM as a way
strong it'll begin
beginning currently our compiler can
automatically fuse and the compiled the
whole graph with 1600 operators into a
single GPU kernel the right figure
demonstrate the performance comparison
with our general Tanz flow the Purvis is
a title OPH means we only applied
operator batching organisations in the
graph layer level organizations and the
diffusion bar is the final results of
kernel fusion we can see with our
compiler we can get about the 10x beat
up for this workload so in conclusion we
think a compiler infrastructure is
critical for both cloud and the ngan
because he can automatically and
transparently on mice both the
distributed training and under the local
inference on the and different devices
and we also think our system innovation
is the k2 brain into the application the
diverse hardware since the the current
year from already abstract common IR
which means to graph data flow graph IR
and we can leverage this to to cope
design software and hardware for extreme
efficiency we also have developed the
volume prototype to demonstrate the
initial improvements it's how it's up to
eight times speed up for training and
10x speed up on the inference workload
thank you as my talk
so do you have a question there the two
protects yeah it's to price but it can
integrate integrate into same platform
because the one weighs the most mostly
target to the framework so computation
framework and the pie is target to how
to schedules job to the different
Silver's so after pie schedule into a
specific Silver's of GPUs so well one
can apply the organization so it can be
interpreted into a same platform but two
different system so why to you can you
can treat them as the two module in a
same system model
yeah but actually it's it to this
different system okay thank you
thank you so the column
kalabaw of miser participial mostly for
multiple servers and and the the local
nights are easy for just a single server
thank you so when you are applying this
this technology you come to the
parameter server just for example so do
training compression on the traffic
between nodes and also the IPS so yeah
currently we are not to apply the
comparison stuff in this work but the
compression is I think that the
technique of a compression so kernel to
this this techniques so we can also
apply the compression into the
transmission it can further reduce the
communication overhead yeah thank you
okay if this is a no other question
that's welcome to the next speaker
good afternoon
ah my name is Fang Yong from citizens
Research Group MS Microsoft Research
Asia and today I'm going to introduce
open pine the open source initiative for
AI platform in China so here's the
background so we we all know that AI
becomes one of the major focus and a
very heated topic across academia and
industries and we believe that there is
six major opportunities to democratize
AI through the innovations on AI
infrastructure that can lower the bar
for newcomers to facilitate a iocai ssin
and to speed up a AI research and also
that could potentially help
accellerate the penetration of AI
technologies across industries
especially for the traditional
industries so we feel that the current
status of the a AI platform is still in
early stage we find that others exist
the ad hoc ways to build and deploy an
AI platform
it's very is relatively easy to build a
small scale of platforms with narrowed
specific servers but do we actually need
to help the entire industry we actually
need a platform that works in different
environment and application scenarios
that include the on-premise cloud and
even hybrid hosting environment and also
that the AI platform not only should can
support domain service peak application
like image video speech language or but
also they need to support them all in
one platform and also for the AI
applications in a certain vertical
domain and this AI platform need to be
highly compatible need to be extensible
it has a very good manageability and
efficiency so before I dig into the
details we do I need to emphasize again
that importance of the AI platform on
the AR platform actually provided
infrastructure support for the advance
of the AI technologies are they actually
support the deep learning algorithms and
frameworks and the AR platform also can
should manage hardware in the easy way a
good platform can boost the innovation
and productivity of different kind of AI
research field it allows the researchers
and AI practitioners to focus on the
innovation itself instead of the hassles
of infrastructure construction
deployment management and optimization
and a good AI platform could enable
result result sharing a good telephone
can help build a community for mutual
knowledge sharing and to help other each
other to leverage the previous research
research result and thus can speed up
that innovation so an open platform for
Aird and education is actually we feel
that it actually helped that
co-development know for a a I innovation
education and the platform evolution so
we can a good platform we can leverage
this platform to design the AI cross
project to perform training to gross the
the AI talent pool and also an open
source the platform can add open source
that the platform can help to encourage
the resource sharing and for
collaborative innovation so here is the
overview of the IMF loan debt in in my
mind the the underlying the
infrastructure layer including hardware
and the various of the deep learning
technology we have we have already build
and upon that we need a management layer
to manage the heterogeneous cluster for
our resources management and scheduling
and we also as Tina mentioned that we
also need a platform to host
system-level intelligent in optimization
and also we could have the platform to
support a deep learning and the
intelligence exploration and based upon
the platform you can build share the
resource for practice or for education
and also the platform can potentially
host at the label there are deep
learning data and also you can leverage
the platform tour and also leverage the
tools for management integration and the
a very a I lifecycle management also our
compiler optimization the cognitive
capability built on the platform
including natural language understanding
visual perception speech recognition as
I mentioned across different domain so
let me focus on the the middle layer the
platform to manage the heterogeneous
cluster so we open sourced the app I
called the open pipe a platform for AI
so this platform is GPU cluster
management infrastructure it has the
following features first it's open so
it's open source it's licensed under MIT
license and it's actually operated in
the open collaboration model we actually
work with various of partners I will
mention that details later and took to
develop and evolve the platform together
and that open parents actually are
extensible it or not not only support
all the major deep learning frameworks
it also I mean
extensible to support a new workload he
also supported diversified hardware
including FPGA GPU and ASIC given that
the drivers are available and open pi
has a the
it has a modular design so you actually
embrace the micro service design
paradigm so every service run in a
container so this micro service choice
can help us replace a certain component
by component a very easily for example
if you would like to have try a
different storage option you can you can
switch from for example HDFS to our
cluster FS and PI also have a good
efficiency its support of very
fine-grained the GPO scheduling also
support the high speed networking
including our DMA accessory Saoirse pi
also has a relatively good manageability
it actually provided a web UI for
preform operator to manage and monitor
the platform and also help the deep
learning user to manage job submission
job or even monitor the hardware
utilization and pi provides some photons
capability so you don't have to deal
worried about the failure and and also
PI learns a lot from Microsoft's
internal practice so we actually
reproduce that production environment
and the realistic is in industrial uses
case for a deep learning model training
scenario here is a high-level overview
of the open point
architecture the underlying is the host
environment that including cloud private
cloud or on-premise cluster that running
out of heterogeneous hardware
gpo cpu fpga RDMA ssh session and on top
data we we support we leverage docker
and kubernetes to perform content
container orchestration and we provide
tools for to deploy the platform easily
and also to upgrade and maintenance and
also we have job management resource
manager and associates SEO so one of the
key things are in our market as read is
that we try to provide a standardized
interface to the deep learning workload
and to the platform management tools so
that as long as the interfaces are
standardized all the all the deep
learning workload or even Big Data are
traditionally big data workload can
leverage this standardize the API run on
this open pipe level and and this would
ensure the portability of the workload
meaning that or once you feel once you
successfully run a deep learning job in
one pie cluster instance it can apply to
I mean running on other PI deployment as
well and also this interface and the
runtime support enable the innovation of
high-level higher level AI service like
a auto email is actually session and
here is a little bit more details of our
current implementation for example you
as I mentioned I use docker we use
kubernetes for cluster management and on
top of that for storage our current
storage option is HDFS because that is
one of the most popular distributed
storage solution and we use Hadoop with
our own extension of GPU support for
complicated GPU scheduling as well as
multi-tenancy support and we are we we
now support all deep learning workload
and some of the big data working like
spark and we have we are also developing
our or our own auto email algorithms and
the platforms that do I will mention
that briefly later on
so with this platform we believe we can
we can build an open ecosystem so our
initial engagement with China ai
community is to have a community to with
the pair platform we can have a lot of
shared resources and tools and build the
cognitive ability so that we can help in
research in education education as well
as growth the talent pool
Microsoft Research Asia now walk with
four major Chinese universe of vernie's
versa T's to have China open AI platform
and aliens those four universities
including picking universities Chinese
University of Science and Technology of
China and ASEAN children University and
George Young University and I would like
to provide one case study for the
schools of information Science and
Technology of us TC this is the this is
their previous practice they have 300
the AI researchers and students with
approximately 400 GPU and their current
pain point is major about operation
overhead because that those are AI
scientists they are not the
infrastructure assistant researchers or
IT profession
so they fear that to operate on a
relatively large scale GPU cluster it's
a it's a lot of work and for each
students and researchers to run a
certain steep learning workload on the
cluster require a lot of work you need
to make sure your your version is
correct for example you have to have the
right version of tensorflow essentially
Setia
and you you you have to be careful not
to screw up other people's environment
like the corrected version of KU DNN
even if you drive or something like that
and as a result that the previous
cluster utilization is relatively low so
with the open point deployment we have
as I mentioned before we have a web UI
interface to help to monitor and manage
that GPL cluster and we actually lower
the learning curve for curve for the air
researches to run deep learning workload
the result the research result can
ensure the cross team with docker image
and the job configuration files that
require different kind of resource like
for example number of GPUs in for the
job and the new user like a new student
when they try to learn try to run some
workload that they could just jump start
with some pre build docker images and
there are their GPU cluster utilization
improved with our our scheduler
mechanisms and they reach the plateau
and around their workload and we are
happy to see that we the open pipe
platform can help them win some of the
top and prestigious award in cvpr
so
to summarize a platform open princess
really a platform for AI innovation it
provided a much-needed a playground for
AI research and development pi actually
is a represent a class of realistic and
the production environment where AI
researchers should target at because
that as I mentioned before Microsoft
internal production environment it's
very much like open PI and it has a free
platform for non professionals by
non-professional I mean IT professionals
or assistant researcher so they we have
a relatively low operation overhead and
we provide the web UI base to job in
management to us so that air researchers
can easily use the platform to run their
AI workload and so the researchers can
focus on AI research in itself in set of
four tedious our IT staff and with the
platform we can we can help the result
serving and reproduce the research
research result as you might know that
it's very hard for a iris researcher to
reproduce other people's workload
because that they often require a lot of
parameter tuning so the our platform can
help you with a darker image that
includes all the parameter you set for
the for the pay-per-view you published
and also the platform can help the
system research itself here I would like
to give a few example of the research
opportunities Systems Group are working
on so for example we are try to explore
it to understand what is the right
system promotive for deep learning
schedule
in a large-scale GPO scheduling for
example in the big data error Big Data
jobs are expressive with MapReduce tasks
and later on we they usually have a dag
scheduling but before the big data area
if you look at the the the distributed
the process they usually are the
scheduling primitively it's usually time
sharing migration essentially session so
what is the right primitive or deep
learnings workload it's our one of our
research focus and also that we feel
that because deep learning workload
usually required large data and larger
neural model sizes so as to have a
relatively good accuracy so we feel that
GP to how to manage GPU memory more
efficiently it's one of the potential
opportunities we can exploit for example
we can leverage a very traditional
system concept like virtual memory and
some of the technology like memory
compression essentially stretcher to
optimize the GPU management in during
deep learning model training and and we
we have identified several case where
certain deep learning technology like
the auto email techno reasons may have
some very subtle interplay with
underlying systems cluster scheduling
how to optimize those deep learning job
that can I mean attack it for achieving
the good model having a good model
neural model instead of only speed up
one specific deep learning chaining
possession
it's one of the interesting research
topic and also like across job
optimization and how to identify
fairness in the case of deep learning
workload especially for the GPU that
those are very interesting research
opportunities that the system research
itself can help so to conclude we have a
platform that can facilitate the
research on artificial intelligence it
provides an efficient and the ease of
use AI infrastructure that can help to
put AI research into practice and the
platform itself is opening the open
collaboration model it we actually
develop the platform with the university
together and we have an open community
we start from China then and we
certainly welcome University and the
researchers or even industry the
practitioners across the worldwide to
join us to develop a platform together
ok thank you
so after that I would like to spend a
few slides to introduce another piece of
work we our team is working on which is
called a neural network intelligent so
here is some I would like to show just a
few slides here is the the overall it's
the the overall process of the deep
learning developers daily practice so
first they they usually can mine or
search some code for a certain deep
learning neuro model practice from
github or related website and our our
neural network intelligent platform can
index those popular code and neural
models and recommend this neural network
model architecture to the user and
neural network intelligence also provide
a lightweight open-source package for
user to run their own training sessions
to find a good neural model and the
finally we have visualized the tools to
edit search and debug the neural network
model in turns during the auto Mao
training session we we know that the the
traditional autumn mao algorithm has
been developed from a simple a simple
hyper parameter tuning to more advanced
the neural architecture search including
for example if evolutionary based search
rain first learning based search or
other more advanced technology and and
then and the later on we have seen that
people are starting to apply neuro
evolution or chance for learning in this
kind of neurological job search so our n
ni PhD actually support all these kind
of technology and also we provide a
markup language for search spaces of
specification for example those those
mock-ups showed in orange it's a way for
user to specify their their choice
during the search space so we feel that
using a markup language actually provide
deep learning researchers are very handy
tours to specify a certain neural never
knew your architecture search okay so we
are going to open source this packaging
maybe one or two months depending on the
legal process who are going through we
hope that in the future we can we can
people will will use this in an AI
package to apply a certain autoimmune or
research so we can enable the more rapid
innovation in the author mao research
itself okay
so that's all for the talk thank you any
questions yes I'm interested in the
ultramel part so could you tell me more
about like what kind of optimal
functionality to support and what's the
usage or consumption from the customer
and growing feature and so on so the so
we decide to open source and any knife
as a lightweight a package so if you
only have one GPO server you can use it
if you have for example ten GPU servers
you can use it and if you happen to have
hundreds of thousands of GPU classes
that they've managed by open bar pie you
can also use it so it's a quite flexible
and we we so the the platform the
package itself that does does include a
certain typical of classic auto ma
algorithm for example random search grid
search or base method but we also our
lab provide interface send standardized
interface allowing now deep learning
researchers to
their own autoimmune or everything which
one of which is actually one of the
active research topic right now and and
so this is one of the target customers
we are we try to support innovator
innovator the other part of the customer
is that the some of the people actually
do not have too much knowledge on deep
learning itself and they would like to
have they would like to have for example
try some CNN model but in order to
better leverage the CNE model they have
to do some fine-tuning for example one
of the very typical training practice is
to retain only the last few layers of
the CNN mode also as to have a better
classification result then we have this
tools that can help you automatically
you have you don't have to do anything
you have just leverage some of the
pre-configured of package so it's this
is just like a Microsoft custom vision
or Google's Auto Emil except that you
can run the entire package open source
and on your own cluster so you can play
with you don't have to lock a lot of
before stew logging into any cloud
offering right I hope that just sounds
good question thank you
we do not support fu G yet so we our
design actually taking a fpga into
account but we need to verify that with
the driver so i assume that if the
driver doesn't have any problem then we
we don't have any problem because that
we cheat GPU as just one specified
specified a coprocessor and the FPGA is
no different than that okay thank you